bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat ce matin les sénateurs examinent
le projet de loi qui tend à éliminer les
armes à sousmunition il s'agit pour la
France de transcrire dans son droit
national la convention d'Oslo qui
interdit la production le transfert et
le stockage des armes à sousmunition qui
cause bien entendu des dommages in
acceptable aux populations civile tout
de suite donc direction l'hémicycle très
bonne matinée à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi tendant à
l'élimination des armes à
sousmunition dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé main
ministre de la Défense monsieur le
ministre vous avez la
parole
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
Commission des Affaires étrangères et de
la défense madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les
sénateurs conçu pour disperser une
grande quantité de projectiles explosif
les armes à sous munition constituent
une menace grave une menace sournoise et
durable car elle laisse sur le terrain
une part significative de sousmunition
non explosé et une menace
particulièrement lâche car elle frppe
avant tout les populations
civiles la France est aux avantpostes
dans la lutte contre ce fléo nous navons
nous avons cessé d'utiliser ce type
d'arme dès
1991 et d'en produire dès 2002 notre
pays a joué un rôle majeur dans
l'élaboration de la convention
d'Oslo que nous avons signé le 3
décembre 2008 et ratifié le 25 septembre
2009 cette convention nous en avons
largement anticipé l'entrée en vigueur
en décidant dès 2008 le retrait du
service opérationnelle de 22000
roquettes M26 à Grenade du lanceroquette
multiple et de 13000 auut 155 mm à
Grenade ces armes sont stockées en
attendant d'être détruites conformément
aux prescriptions de la convention
d'Oslo et aussi en
présentant dès le 25 novembre dernier un
projet de loi d'application au Conseil
des ministres c'est précisément ce texte
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
vous est aujourd'hui soumis et
permettez-moi tout d'abord de de
remercier chaleureusement madame la
rapporteur du projet de loi madame gar
Mélan vous investissez depuis longtemps
sur ce sujet et votre expertise était
extrêmement utile pour l'élaboration de
ce projet de loi permettez-moi également
de saluer le président de la commission
de la défense des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Jocelin drouan qui a fait en
sorte que le texte soit eximiné en
conditions dans des conditions
extrêmement
satisfaisantes ce projet de loi
s'inscrit pleinement dans l'esprit de la
lettre de la convention d'Oslo il
témoigne de notre volonté de respecter
rigoureusement les engagements souscrits
par la France il prévoit d'abord
l'interdiction toutes circonstances des
armes à soumunition qu'il s'agisse
d'emploi de mise au point de production
d'acquisition de stockage de
conservation de transfert de fabrication
d'offr de cession d'importation de
cession de commerce ou d'exportation
cette interdiction s'accompagne de
peinees Lourdes et de délais de
prescription allongé qui sont
dérogatoires du droit commun elle
s'accompagne également de la possibilité
pour la France de poursuivre l'un de ses
ressortissants même si ont été commis en
dehors du territoire sur même si les
faits n'ont pas été commis pardon sur le
territoire national et même s'ils ne
sont pas punis par la législation du
pays dans lequel ils ont été commis le
texte prévoit également la destruction
par les armées de leur stock d'armes à
souminution dès que possible dans un
délai de 8 ans à compté de l'entrée en
vigueur de la Convention cette
destruction sera entièrement financée
par le ministère de la Défense pour un
coût estimé entre 20 et 30 millions
d'euros et C sera achevé pour nous en
2016 conformément aux modalité de la
convention le texte autorise néanmoins
la la conservation d'un stock d'armes à
sousmunition ce stock sera limité aux
besoins strictement nécessaires aux
activités de formation et de mise au
point des techniques de de détection
d'enlèvement ou de destruction des armes
il faut que nos
sapeurs puissent continuer à se formmer
sur de types d'armes le projet de loi
propose enfin un suivi rigoureux des
stocks d'armes à sousmunition il prévoit
d'étendre les compétences de la
commission nationale pour l'élimination
des mines antipersonnels au suivi de la
loi d'application de la convention
d'Oslo et il prévoit également la
réalisation annuelle par le ministère
des Affaires étrangères d'un
compte-rendu destiné au secrétariat
général de l'ONU le ministère de la
Défense bien entendu apportera tout son
concours à cet
exercice naturellement conformément aux
modalités aussi de cette convention
d'Oslo ce projet de loi n'interdit pas
les actions de coalition avec les pays
non signataires et c'est un point
essentiel si nous voulons convaincre nos
alliés de nous rejoindre dans cet
engagement en conclusion mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs déjà signateur
de la convention d'Otawa sur les min
personnelles la France est fière
aujourd'hui d'être au premier rang des
grands pays qui s'engage dans ce cadre
cette exemplarité nous sommes déterminés
à en faire preuve en matière d'armes à
sousmunition et avec ce projet de loi
nous avons l'opportunité de contribuer
plus efficacement à lutter contre Cees
fléau
nous disposons enfin d'un atout majeur
pour convaincre nos partenaires de nous
rejoindre de ce combat avec ce texte la
France est au rendez-vous de la
responsabilité et de l'humanisme je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre dans
la discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Joë garot MAM rapporteur de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées mes chers
collègues nous vous
écoutonsés merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
constitue la traduction concrète de
l'engagement de la France en faveur de
l'élimination d'armes qui ont causé de
par le monde des dommages humanitaires
considérables je ne reviendrai pas sur
un constat que nous avons déjà pu
dresser à plusieurs reprises que ce soit
dans le rapport d'information que
j'avais présenté dès 2006 avec mon
collègue jean-Pierre Plancade où lors de
la discussion devant notre assemblée de
la convention d'Oslo en septembre
dernier rappelons simplement qu'en
raison de leurs caractéristiques de leur
mode de fonctionnement de la manière
dont elles ont été utilisées par
certaines armées les armes à
sousmunition ont provoqué de manière
durable des conséquences désastreuses et
inacceptables sur les populations
civiles notamment les enfants dans de
nombreuses zones de conflit la
convention d'Oslo représente une très
grande avancée du droit international
humanitaire puisqu'elle pose le principe
d'interdiction de ses armes à
l'exception de celles répondant à des
critères extrêmement précis et stricts
garantissant un effet circonscrit aux
objectifs
militaires c'est avec une très grande
satisfaction que la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense a
accueilli ce projet de loi de
transposition en droit interne de la
convention
d'Oslo en effet nous avons constaté que
le gouvernement avait très fidèlement
veillé à reprendre les obligations
déroulants de la convention ce qui
traduit la volonté de la France d'en
appliquer pleinement toutes les
dispositions la Commission s'est
également félicitée de la rapidité avec
laquelle la France entant mettre en
œuvre cet instrument nous avons retiré
du service des armes interdite par la
Convention avant même la signature de
celle-ci nous avons été le 20e état la
ratifier 9 mois à peine après sa
signature et nous prenons dans la foulée
les mesures législatives
nécessaires nous souhaitons évidemment
qu'après le vote du Sénat aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale puisse très
prochainement examiner ce texte cela
nous permettrait en effet de promulguer
la loi avant le 1er août prochain date à
laquelle la convention de slow entrera
en vigueur dans tous les États qui l'ont
ratifié ce projet de loi est un texte
bref qui insère un nouveau chapitre dans
la partie du code de la défense relative
aux armes
interdites ce chapitre relatif aux armes
à sousmunition vient à la suite de celui
consacré au mine antipersonnel sur
lequel il est largement calqué le projet
de loi retient un champ d'interdiction
rigoureusement non conforme à celui de
la convention d'Oslo renvoyant à
celle-ci pour la définition des armes
prohibées il reprend la clause de la
convention relative à
l'interopérabilité cette clause exclut
que la participation à une opération
militaire international au côté d'un
pays possédant ou utilisant des armes à
sousmunition tombe sous le cûp de
l'interdiction sous réserve qu'il n'y
ait pas d'implication dans leur mise en
œuvre il s'aligne également sur la
Convention ce qui concerne les délais de
destruction et il précise le nombre très
réduit d'armes prohibées que certains
services de l'État pourront conservé
conformément à la convention pour la
mise au point des techniques de
détection et des contre-mesures et pour
la formation au
déminage le projet de loi met en place
le régime de déclaration auprès du
ministère de la défense des armes à
sousmunition détenue qu'ell soit
destinée à être détruite ou à être
conservée au fin de recherche et de
formation il habilite certains agents du
ministère de la défense ainsi que les
fonctionnaires des douanes à constater
les infractions enfin le régime pénal
rigoureux prévu par le texte est
analogue à celui existant pour les mines
antipersonnelles il lève le principe de
double incrimination ce qui permettra de
réprimer les infractions à la loi
française commise à l'étranger par un
ressortissant français même si l'État
concerné ne possède pas de législation
équivalente le texte élaboré par la
commission sur lequel nous délibérons
aujourd'hui incorpore neuf amendements
que nous avons apporté au texte initial
du gouvernement outre quelques
amendements d'ordre rédactionnel ou de
précisionion nous avons voulu compléter
la définition des armes interdites afin
d'y inclure les petites bombes
explosives puisque la convention les
assimile aux armes à souousmunition il
nous a paru également souhaitable de
mentionner dans la loi comme le fait la
convention que la destruction des armes
interdites interviendra dès que possible
à cet égard je me félicite monsieur le
ministre que vous ayez confirmé devant
la commission votre intention d'achever
cette destruction en 2016 2 ans avant la
date butoire prévue je rappelle qu'il
s'agit de démanteler environ 35000 obus
ou requête comprenant près de 15
Millions de sousmunitions nous sommes
sensibles à votre eng à celui du
Gouvernement sur ce point d'autant qu'il
implique un coût de l'ordre de 20 à 30
millions d'euros pour le budget de la
défense nous espérons bien évidemment
qu'une filière française de
démantèlement pourra être mise en place
à défaut de quoi il faudrait confier ces
marchés à des industriels étrangers ce
que nous regretterions bien sûr la
Commission a également souhaité
mentionné à l'article 5 relatif à
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi la date du
1er août 2010 qui est celle d'entrer en
vigueur de la convention afin de marquer
notre souhait d'un achèvement rapide du
processus
législatif enfin nous avons adopté un
article additionnel qui permettra
d'élargir les attributions de la
commission nationale pour l'élimination
des mines antipersonnelles lacnema
regroupant des parlementaires et j'ai
l'honneur d'y représenter le Sénat des
responsables des ministères des Affaires
étrangères et de la défense et des
représentants de la société civile et
notamment d'organisations
internationales qui ont beaucoup milité
sur ce texte laacnema constitue une
instance de concertation et de suivi
particulièrement utile pour la mise en
œuvre de la convention d'Otawa sur les
mines antipersonnelles la Commission a
considéré qu'elle avait naturellement
vocation à assurer le même type de
travail pour la mise en œuvre de la
convention d'osloow puisque beaucoup de
problématiques sont connexes notamment
le déminage et l'assistance humanitaire
pour conclure je voudrais me féliciter
du chemin parcouru en quelques années
depuis la lente prise de conscience
sucité par les organisations
humanitaires auxquel je veux encore
rendre hommage jusqu'au lancement du
processus d'Oslo en 2007 à la conclusion
de la convention et à l'examen
aujourd'hui de ce projet de loi je
voudrais également souligner
l'engagement de la France dans ce combat
engagement d'autant plus significatif
qu'à la différence de beaucoup d'États
signataires la France est un acteur
militaire de premier rang engagé et
exposé sur de nombreux théâtres
d'opération l'adoption de la loi de mise
en œuvre de la convention d'Oslo ne
serait toutefois constitué qu'une étape
beaucoup restent malheureusement à
accomplir en matière de déminage et
d'aide aux victimes dans les régions
affectées par les
sousmunitions je pense notamment au
sudliban gravement frappé lors du
conflit de 2006 mais également au pays
du Sud-Est asiatique où les conséquences
de l'emploi des armes à sousmunition
continue à se faire sentir plus de 35
ans après la fin de la guerre du
Vietnam enfin il nous faut œuvrer sans
relâche à l'universalisation de la
convention actuellement 90 % du stock
mondial d'armes à sousmunition est
détenu par des États non signataires il
est donc indispensable de convaincre
certains de nos partenaires
internationaux actuellement attentistes
ou réticents tels que les États-Unis la
Russie la Chine l'Inde le Brésil le
Pakistan Israël la Turquie ou même
certains États de l'Union européenne
comme la Finlande la Grèce la Pologne ou
la Roumanie c'est donc en ayant
pleinement conscience du chemin restant
à parcourir qu'au nom de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
je vous demande mes chers collègu
d'adopter ce projet de loi et je vous en
remercie merci madame le
rapporteur dans la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue Robert U
pour le groupe CRC
SPG monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues avec le projet de loi sur
l'élimination des armes à sousmunition
que nous examinons ce matin nous
arrivons au terme d'un long processus
qui marque une importante avancée du
droit humanitaire
international concernant en particulier
la protection des populations civiles
qui sont les principales victimes de ces
armes nous devons maintenant adapter
dans notre droit national les
dispositions de la Convention dite
d'Oslo lors de la discussion du projet
de loi de ratification ici même en
septembre de l'année dernière j'avais eu
l'occasion d'évoquer le lencheminement
de plusieurs années qui avaient été
nécessaire pour aboutir à cette étape
significative sur la voie du désarmement
j'avais aussi souligné le rôle
déterminant joué par les organisations
non gouvernementales au plan national et
international
pour sensibiliser les opinions publiques
à cette cause et peser sur les décisions
des gouvernement je n'y reviendrai pas
car il ne s'agit pas ce matin de
rappeler des choses que nous avons déjà
examiné rappelé en septembre dernier
notamment mais il faut en revanche
apprécier à sa juste valeur le résultat
de tous ces
efforts je voudrais notamment relever le
rôle très positif joué par notre pays
tout au long de ce processus ceci bien
qu'il ait fallu qu'il soit souvent
aiguillonné par les ONG qui sont
Handicap International la CroixRouge ou
bien encore amnestie internationale
comme c'est d'ailleurs leur rôle pour
pour ne prendre que la dernière période
nos armées ont retiré du service les
armes interdite par la Convention bien
avant la signature la France a très
rapidement ratifieré cette convention et
enfin nous examinons les mesures
législatives nécessaires à son
application avant même la date de son
entrée en vigueur au plan international
je reconnais volontiers que cela
témoigne concrètement de la volonté
conforme à nos valeurs républicaines de
parvenir à l'élimination totale de ces
armes tellement contrairees au droit
humanitaire l'affirmation de cette
volonté pèse d'un grand poids à travers
le le monde quand on sait le rôle que
joue notre pays au plan international en
tant que membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU mais aussi la place
qu'il tient parmi les grandes puissances
militaires globalement ce projet de loi
d'adaptation dans notre droit national
traduit fidèlement l'ensemble des
avancées positives contenues dans la
convention d'Oslo que ce soit à propos
des de mesures précises de transparence
sur la destruction des stocks et la
rétention de ce type d'armes de
sanctions pénales fortes ou bien encore
de l'établissement d'une juridiction
extraterritoriale permettant de
sanctionner ces activités commises à
l'étranger par des ressortissants
français le projet de loi va même dans
certains cas un peu plus loin en
élargissant par exemple la notion
d'assistance aux activités illégales
définies par la
Convention notre com missission a en
outre utilement précisé et complété
quelques aspects qui portent sur les
définitions la destruction des stocks et
surtout l'élargissement du champ
d'intervention de la commission
nationale pour l'élimination des mines
antiersonnel tout ceci étant dit je
regrette pourtant que sur certains
aspects et non des moindres le projet de
loi qui nous est présenté ne soit pas
plus précis et plus contraignant par
rapport à certaines obligations
contenues dans la convention je
comprends tout à fait que l'urgence soit
aujourd'hui de convaincre les nombreux
pays n'ayant pas encore signé
ou ratifié cette convention qui est une
base minimum de le faire mais j'estime
pourtant que notre pays pourrait avec
d'autres créer un effet d'entraînement
en prenant quelques mesures importantes
précisant certaines obligations je vise
là très concrètement la question de
l'interdiction des investissements et
des financements par les États
signataires des activités qui ont tr qui
ont trait aux armes à
sousmunition en effet la convention
d'Oslo dans son article 1c permet
implicitement d'interdire aux États
signataires de financer ou d'investir
dans des entreprises fabriquants ou
commercial an ces armes implicitement
car ceci est évoqué de façon détournée
par l'obligation faite aux états de ne
pas encourager je cite ou assister une
activité interdite par la Convention ces
formulation très générale entraîne une
incertitude juridique qui permet de
nombreuses interprétations de nature à
échapper aux interdictions je je
regrette donc monsieur le ministre qu'en
considérant que l'interprétation de ces
notions est assez large elle peut
suffire à interdire partiellement ses
financements il me semble qu'il y a
pourtant là une ambigué qu'il faudrait
lever ce serait un acte très concret
marquant et marquant davantage encore
notre engagement dans le combat contre
les armes à
sousmunition il y a bien une ambigué
dans cette position car pourquoi
infirmer affir met une interdiction sans
se donner tous les moyens de la faire
respecter par parenthèse cette réflexion
est également valable pour d'autres
domaines de l'action gouvernementale il
est évident que le financement ou
l'investissement de ce type d'activité
est une des conditions de leur existence
dès lors il faut que les choses soient
clairement dites dans la loi monsieur le
ministre écoutez ce que vous disent sur
cette question les associations qui s'en
préoccupent mais prenez aussi en compte
l'une des recommandations formulées par
cette haute autorité administrative
indépendante qu'est la Commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme je cite volontiers ce point
précis j'ouvre lesingm afin de lever
toute ambiguïé juridique sur le principe
comme sur l'interprétation inscrire de
manière explicite dans la loi
l'interdiction des investissements et
des financements tant direct indirect
dans des entreprises menant même
partiellement des activités prohibées et
lié aux armes à sousmunition ce sont les
propos de la commission nationale ce
serait une mesure qui traduirait
concrètement la ferme volonté de notre
pays d'éliminer ces armes et qui se
mettrai en conformité avec des réalités
existant déjà dans notre pays et à
l'étranger en France par exemple à la
suite d'une action conjointe menée
depuis 2006 par les branches françaises
d'amnestie internationale et Handicap
International de grands groupes
financiers et d'assurance se sont
publiquement dotés de code de bonne
conduite excluant toute forme
d'investissement et ou de financement de
ce
secteur adopter une telle disposition
législative ne pourrait que les
conforter dans leur action parallèlement
d'un strict de vu économique et non plus
simplement éthique la position de pays
comme le Luxembourg et la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui ont interdit ces
financement ou bien la Suisse
l'Allemagne et les Pays-Bas qui
prévoient de le faire devrai lever la
crainte qu'à votre gouvernement de
porter atteinte à la compétitivité de
nos entreprises j'avais bien entendu les
arguments à l'époque que vous aviez
avancés enfin je pense qu'il faudrait
également compléter cette mesure par
l'élargissement de la compétence
extraterritoriale de nos juridictions à
la possibilité de poursuivre aussi des
personnes morales pour cesdlit c'est le
sens des amendements que nous avons
déposé sur ce texte en conclusion
monsieur le ministre le groupe
communiste républicains citoyens et des
sénateurs du Parti de Gauche souhaite
que vous preniez en compte nos remarques
compte tenu de l'importante avancée que
représente globalement ce texte en
faveur du droit humanitaire
international et que j'ai évoqué dans
largement dans mon intervention nous
voterons ce projet de loi sur
l'élimination des armes à
sousmunition merci merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à pour le groupe
socialiste à Madame Monique Pigier ben
Guiga
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues par ce texte la France avance
dans un processus
législatif qui vise à
éliminer les armes les plus perverses
dont l'usage cause des dommages
physiques irréversibles à des
populations civiles je rends hommage au
nom de mon groupe aux ONG qui ont été à
la pointe de ce combat handicap
international Amnesy la Croix-Rouge et
qui nous ont permis de mieux mesurer à
quel point il était urgent de mettre fin
à une telle
barbarie la loi du 21 septembre 2009 a
autorisé la ratification de la
Convention sur les armes à sousmunition
première partie du processus initié avec
la signature par la France de la
convention multilatérale relative aux
armes à sousmunition dénomé nommé
convention d'Oslo qui interdit
l'utilisation la production le transfert
et le stockage des armes à
soumunition étant donné le grand nombre
de pays qui ont ratifié cette convention
nous pouvons espérer une entrée en
vigueur dès le 1er août 2010 et comme
notre rapporteur je pense qu'il est
souhaitable que la loi que nous dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui soit
promulguée avant cette date cette loi
constitue une avancée considérable pour
les protection pour la protection des
populations civiles principales victimes
de ces armes parfois très longtemps
après la fin des hostilités nous
approuvons la décision du gouvernement
quand il a décidé de soumettre
rapidement au vote du Parlement ce
projet de loi le tribut humain des armes
à sousmunition est bien trop lourd au
regard du droit international
l'utilisation massive de ce type d'arme
en Asie du sud-est comme le rappelait
notre rapporteur par l'armée américaine
et au Liban au cours de l'été 2006 par
l'armée israélienne a suscité une
véritable prise de conscience leur
emploi dans des zones habitées et
cultivé conjoint à leur fort effet de
dispersion entraînent un pourcentage
très élevé de victimes civiles des
enfants notamment puisque de nombreux
types de bombes évoquent des jouets il
fait subir aux populations civiles un
risque majeur sur le long terme en
raison du dysfonctionnement très
important de ces armes qui restent sur
le terrain où elles ont atterri sans
avoir explosé et constittu parfois des
années après la fin des conflits une
menace quotidienne intolérable qui
interdit par exemple la culture des
terres cette convention constitue un
outil juridique international
contraignant qui permet d'aller bien
plus loin que les textes antérieurs tel
tel la convention du 10 octobre 1980 sur
l'interdiction ou la limitation de
certaines armes classiques cette
convention s'était réservée s'était
révélée
insuffisante la convention d'Otawa sur
l'interdiction de l'emploi du stockage
de la production et du transfert des
mines antipersonnel et sur leur
destruction constitue un un modèle
d'instrument juridique international
contraignant comme ma collègue Catherine
taskaa l'avait déjà souligné en
septembre 2009 lors de la discussion sur
la ratification de cette convention je
veux saluer le choix de Lionel Jospin
lors de sa son arrivée au responsabilité
en
1997 d'inscrire notre pays dans cette
dynamique internationale pour le
désarmement que la reprise des essais
nucléaires en 4 94 et 95 avait stoppé en
uvrant pour la signature de la
convention d'Otawa et en faisant
procéder à sa ratification le 8 juillet
1998 le gouvernement de la France avait
relancé le processus de désarmement pour
C type d'armes la convention d'Oslo
poursuit cette œuvre et l'on peut saluer
la continuité de l'action de la France
dans ce domaine d'un gouvernement à
l'autre d'une majorité à
l'autre la deuxè partie de ce processus
concerne en France l'adaptation en droit
en droit national des prescriptions de
la convention c'est donc l'objet de du
projet de loi dont dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'un texte positif
très
attendu ce projet de loi procède à une
adaptation fidèle en droit interne des
des préconisation de la convention mais
et nous tenons à le saluer ce projet de
loi va parfois encore plus loin que le
texte de la convention en particulier en
ce qui concerne la notion d'assistance
les mesures de transparence et la
définition des armes
concernées monsieur le ministre je
m'efforce de rendre hommage en ce moment
à l'action de votre gouvernement et je
serais heureuse que vous
m'écoutiez
l'interdiction
inciter ou encourager quiconque à
s'engager dans les activités couvertes
par la Convention implique
l'interdiction de la fabrication de
l'offre de la cession de l'exportation
et de l'importation du commerce et du
courtage ce qui est une première dans un
projet de loi connexe au régime des
matériels de guerre armes et munitions
il faut toutefois il faut toutefois rel
relativiser un
peu cette C ce progrès dans la mesure où
la notion de courtage n'existe pas en
droit français mais nous y
reviendront le projet de loi prévoit des
mesures précises de transparence sur la
destruction des stocks et la détention
d'armes à sousmunition et nous allons
dans notre
discussion proposer d'aller plus loin
dans le bon sens de ce texte nous
souhaitons renforcer un certain nombre
de ces
orientations par exemple il conviendrait
d'insister sur l'interdiction faite à
toute entreprise de financer d'une
manière directe ou indirecte en France
ou à l'étranger des activités condamnées
par la Convention d'Oslo financer une
entreprise fabriquant ou commercialisant
des armes à sous munition revient à
encourager dans une activité revient à
encourager une activité interdite à la
Convention aussi bien que ce point soit
implicite il faut comprendre que que
l'interdiction d'insistance en son
article 1 c comme visant les
financements dans des entreprises qui
produisent ou commercialisent des armes
à sousmunition et là nous avons un
problème avec nos relations très
étroites en particulier avec l'industrie
d'armement israélien et qui dont
certaines entreprises avec lesquelles
nous sommes liés fabrique par ailleurs
des armes de
sousmunition dès lors ne respecte pas
les obligations prévues par le traité
tout établissement financier
investissant ou finançant des
entreprises engagées dans les activités
liées aux armes à sousmunition prohibé
par la Convention d'Oslo pour respecter
aussi bien l'esprit que la lettre de
cette dernière et pour éviter tout flou
juridique la France devrait donc prévoir
expressément dans ce projet de loi
l'interdiction de toute forme de
financement qu'il s'agisse de
financement direct ou indirect il nous
semble également que la question
relative à la définition précise des
termes transfert et transit concernant
les opérations de circulation d'armes à
sousmunition d'un état à un autre par la
voie terrestre maritime ou aérienne et
aussi la question de l'interdiction de
courtage nécessite quelques explications
puisque cette notion de courtage est peu
précisée dans la loi française
malheureusement nous ne pouvons ignorer
que les États-Unis la Russie la Chine
l'Inde le Pakistan et Israël ne sont pas
partis à la Convention or ce le principe
d'interopérabilité inscrit dans la
convention autorise bien les états
partis à participer à des actions
militaires conjointes avec des États qui
utiliseraient des bombes à sous munition
ce principe est certes compréhensible du
point de vue du réalisme politique et
diplomatique mais elle cette disposition
réduit de façon importante la portée
juridique et pratique du texte et nous
devons tout faire pour inciter les États
non non encore signataires de la
convention à la
ratifier monsieur le monsieur le
ministre en conclusion pouvez-vous
assurer à la représentation nationale
que à défaut de s'interdire de s'engager
dans une coopération et des opérations
militaires avec des États non partis à
la Convention en Afghanistan par exemple
au côté des États-Unis la France
n'acceptera pas de prendre part à des
opérations militaires au cours
desquelles serait employé par nos alliés
des armes à
sousmunition si l'on doit comprendre que
la France n'exclut pas de s'engager dans
des opérations militaires au cours
desquelles seraient employé des armes à
sousmunition je ne suis pas certaine que
cette prise de distance avec l'esprit de
la convention serait de nature à incité
les États non signataires à devenir
partie de celle-ci sur ce point monsieur
le ministre nous demandons des
éclaircissements
merci Maes chers collègues dans la suite
de la discussions la parole est à
François Fortassin pour le
RDSE monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
invités à adopter un texte ayant pour
but de transcrire en droit français les
dispositions de la Convention d'oselo
sur les armes à sousmunition convention
ratifiée pour la France en
2009 conçu pour disperser sur une large
surface une grande quantité de
projectiles explosifs ces armes ont
provoqué dans la vingtaine de pays où
ils on été utilisés des dommages
humanitaires disproportionnés au regard
de leur justification militaire nous
sommes face à la dernière marche d'un
long processus d'interdiction totale de
ce type d'
il est temps d'aller au bout de ce long
processus juridique et
politique le Sénat sononore de sêtre
intéressé à cette question à plusieurs
reprises ces dernières années en effet
un rapport d'information rédigé par
notre excellent collègue Jean-Pierre
planca de nous alerter dès 2006 de la
gravité de la situation humanitaire liée
à l'utilisation des armes à sous
munition depuis
plus
je vous donne un acte de
cela je vous en donne un acte monsieur
le
Président depuis plus de 20 ans la
communauté internationale s'insurge
contre ce type d'armement créé pour
lutter contre les unités blindé et ce
type d'armement n'a plus aucune
justification militaire de nos jours
faillible et dépassé les armes à
souousmunition sont une menace pour les
populations civiles non plus pendant
mais surtout après la fin des conflits
de raisons essentielles peuvent être
avancé pour expliquer cette odieuse
réalité d'abord un rayon d'action très
important de ces armes pour certains
modèles notamment ensuite à cause de
leur faillibilité elle créent de
nombreux restes explosifs qui provoquent
un risque permanent
d'explosion d'autre part leur aspect
brillant elle ressemble parfois des des
canettes de soda peuvent attirer les
enfants depuis des décennies les armes à
sousmunition ué de nombreux champs de
bataille à travers la planète on peut
citer notamment le Laos le Vietnam où 35
ans après les derniers bombardements
américains plusieurs dizaines de civils
sont tués ou blessés chaque année du
fait des sousmunitions non encore
explosé les peuples afghans libanais ou
kosovar ont été aussi victimes de ce
véritable fléo plus récemment encore les
territoires palestinien en 2006 et
georgien en 2008 ont été le théâtre de
conflit dans lesquel ces armes ont été
employés alors que le nombre de victimes
avérées s'élève à 11000 certaines
évaluations globales notamment celles
réalisé par Handicap International vont
jusqu'à avancer le chiffre 100000
victimes depuis
73 conscient de la gravité de la
situation un groupe d'État est parvenu à
relancer une discussion internationale
ayant vocation à interdire totalement ce
type de matériel prenant rapidement de
l'ampleur lors de la conférence diplom
tique de bublin en mai 2008 cette
démarche a abouti à la signature d'un
texte par 96 pays le 4 décembre de cette
même année à
oselou pour la première fois la
communauté internationale s'est dotée
d'un texte prohibant les armes sous
munition ce texte marque une avancée
capitale dans les domaines du
désarmement de la dépollution de la
neutralisation de ces armes mais aussi
ce qui mérite d'être souligné dans la
prise en charge des populations civiles
victimes si le projet de loi reprenait
l'essentiel de la convention nous
pouvons saluer le travail de la
commission qui est venu à juste titre y
adjoindre certaines précisions telles
que l'extension du mandat de la
commission nationale pour l'élimination
des miles antipersonnel qui avait par
nature compétence assurer le suivi de la
mise en œuvre de la convention ou
prévoir que la destruction des stocks
d'armes à soumission devra se faire le
plus rapidement possible ce processus
d'interdiction n'est pas sans rappeler
celui concernant les mines
antipersonnels d'autre part il faut dans
les deux cas rappeler le rôle
prépondérant et se féliciter des des
organisations non que les organisations
non gouvernementales ont été les
premières à alertter les états sur le
drame qui était en train de se dérouler
d'autre part elle a aussi abouti à un
instrument juridique ici la convention
d'Otawa signée les 3 ou 4 décembre 97
dont la portée est malheureusement
dans les deux hypothèses des pays
producteurs et utilisateurs d'armes à
souousmunition ne font pas partie de la
Convention et on peut citer en
particulier les États-Unis la Russie ou
encore l'Israël etou la Serbie ou ce oui
et la Chine et où se sont déroulé
malheureusement en Serbie
des atrocités d'une façon énorme et de
façon aussi très une période très
récente à l'heure actuelle moins de la
moitié des états producteurs et à peine
un cè des état utilisateurs ont adhéré à
la à la convention dans ces conditions
il faut se réjouir de l'élimination des
armes à soumunition que nous sommes
invités à voter aujourd'hui il ne faut
pas occulter la réalité qu'afin qu'un
maximum d'utilisateurs de producteurs
nous rejoignent au sein de la convention
d'osselour si le chemin sera long avant
qu'elle devienne une véritable norme
internationale s'imposant à tous et
conduisant à l'éradication pure et
simple ce calamité elle a au moins le
mérite que nous ayons ont pris à ce
niveau un certain nombre d'initiatives
qui qui sont saluées de façon
internationale et il est bon que au
regard de nos valeurs et que la patrie
des Droits de l'Homme sononore de ce
type d'action notre pays a depuis
l'origine un rôle moteur puisque la
France était partie prenante aux
discussions internationales qui avait
abouti quelques mois plus tard à la
Convention d'Oslo il est à Notter que la
France a d'autre part retiré plus de 90
% de ses stock d'armes à
sousmunition dans le même sens le vote à
l'unanimité des deux assemblées de la
loi du 22 septembre 2009 tendant à la
ratification de la Convention constitue
un signal fort de l'engagement de la
France dont nous pouvons là aussi que
nous féliciter de façon très forte ayant
pour effet d'encrer la convention
d'oselo et ainsi l'élimination des armes
à sousmunition en droit français
l'ensemble des membres de mon groupe
apporte un soutien total à ce texte et
nous espérons bien entendu que
l'unanimité des sénateurs en FR
de merci mon cher collègue dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à notre collègue Bernadette Dupont
apparenté
UMP
bonjour monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues si mon
propos pour certains de mes propos
présenteront une répétition par rapport
à tout ce qui a été dit précédemment il
ne faudra considérer qu'il ne feront que
marteler une réalité et une vérité donc
au nom d'abord au nom du groupe UMP et
probablement de l'ensemble de mes
collègues je voudrais saluer l'excellent
travail et la détermination de notre
collègue Joël garomam sur un sujet sur
le qu elle travaille depuis de
nombreuses années avec la détermination
qu'on lui connaît la séance de ce matin
me semble-t-il revit un caractère
quelque peu solennel ce projet de loi
est le fruit de notre engagement sur la
scène internationale en faveur du
désarmement et du respect du droit
humanitaire vous me permettrez mes chers
collègues de me réjouir de l'inscription
à l'ordre du jour de ce texte et de sa
rapidité depuis la ratification trop
souvent il faut attendre plusieurs
années entre la signature d'un traité ou
d'une convention internationale et le
vote du projet de loi autorisant sa
ratification par les parlements
nationaux il faut encore attendre
quelques années pour qu'il soit
transposé dans notre droit commun et là
à peine plus d'un un an après la
signature de la convention par la France
à Oslo en décembre 2008 nous voilà en
train d'adapter notre code de la défense
à ce titre je tiens à vous remercier
monsieur le ministre il en va également
de la édibilité de la France en tant
qu'acteur du désarmement au sein des
autres puissances de la communauté
internationale mais aussi de notre
crédibilité vis-à-vis comme vous l'avez
dit madame le sénateur et madame le
rapporteur vis-à-vis des organisations
humanitaires et des associations dont il
faut saluer l'égale détermination en vue
de l'élimination de ces armes à
sousmunition armes terribles
initialement conçu pour détruire des
concentrations de véhicules blindés ces
armes présentent la possibilité
d'atteindre indre des cibles sur des
surfaces étendues en utilisant moins de
munitions que les explosifs classiques
composé d'une munition mère ces bombes
obus ou roquette dispersent plusieurs
munitions destinées à exploser à
l'impact mais la réalisé la réalité bien
différente sur le terrain vous l'avez
dit monsieur le ministre pour les
populations civiles depuis plus de 40
années ce système d'armes a été utilisé
dans une trentaine de pays du VI à
l'iraac en 1991 et en 2003 en passant
par le Kosovo le sud Liban en 2006 la
geéorgie et l'Afghanistan leur isage ne
s'est pas limité aux seules cible
militaire hélas et le problème majeur de
ce système d'armes comme il a déjà été
dit tient à leur taux de
dysfonctionnement beaucoup trop élevé
par rapport aux autres armes
conventionnelles après avoir été largué
certaines armes à sousmunition demeurent
au sol sans exploser or C restes
explosives peuvent rester actifs pendant
des années après l'arrêt des hostilités
et c'est là l'objet de tous les dangers
ces armes s'apparentent ni plus ni moins
des mines antipersonnel qui mutilent des
populations tant dans leur chair que
dans leur territoire le sud Liban en est
une dramatique illustration monsieur le
ministre sur ce point pourriez-vous nous
éclairer quant aux opérations de
dépollution des sols dans cette partie
du
pays mes chers collègues je tiens à
souligner la qualité du travail accompli
également par notre commission nous ne
sommes pas cantonnés au simple respect
de l'article 9 de la Convention d'Oslo
qui nous invite à prendre les mesures
réglementaires et dispositions
législatives qui permettront
l'application pleine et entière de la
convention les modifications que nous
avons souhaité apporter au Code de la
défense aux articles du Code de la
défense dépassent le stade de la simple
transposition je veux parler notamment
de l'article L 2344 4 relatif à la
destruction de nos stocks il y est
introduit l'obligation d'une exécution
rapide dans un temps précis de leur
élimination cela démontre notre volonté
de rigueur et notre souci de précision
de même on ne peut que se féliciter de
l'extension du mandat de la commission
nationale pour l'élimination des mines
antipersonnelles la cnepma verra
désormais ses attributions élargies et
assurera une mission de suivi de la
appation de la convention d'Oslo en plus
de celle d'Otawa cela témoinene à la
fois d'une vision globale de la France
en vue du désarmement et de son
attachement au droits
humanitaires je voudrais vous livrer
maintenant quelques observations sur le
rôle que devrai jouer les membres de
l'Union européenne en faveur du
désarmement et de cette convention en
particulier l'intégration au sein de la
Communauté européenne ne peut se limiter
au simple respect du PACT de stabilité
financire ou d'autres critères d'ordre
économique c'est aussi une communauté de
valeurs parmi lesquelles celle du
respect de la vie humaine il est donc
primordial que nos partenaires européens
non seulement signent mais ratifient
cette convention le sol européen le
Kosovo en particulier est contaminé par
ces restes explosifs et si les forces
européenes accomplissent un travail
postcflit dans bien des domaines il n'en
demeure pas moins que les pays
bénéficiant d'opération de maintien de
la paix ou d'aide de l'UE bien que
n'étant pas membre devrait être parti à
la Convention
d'Oslo pouvez-vous à cet effet monsieur
le ministre nous dire si l'Espagne
poursuit à la tête de l'UE l'action et
la promotion de la convention menée
précédemment par la France enfin je vous
rappelle mes chers collègues que la
convention d'Oslo ne nous a pas empêché
de voter en juillet dernier la loi de
programmation militaire 2009-24 14 et
nous avons ainsi adapté à nos
engagements
excusez-moi ce projet de loi constitue
donc un aboutissement de la politique
que nous avons mené depuis
1996 année où nous avons décidé le
retrait et la destruction des
lance-grenades BLG 66 ou système beloua
de notre
arsenal pour terminer je dirais donc
qu'en adoptant projet de loi notre pays
adresse un message symbolique à la
communauté internationale c'est la
démonstration qu'il est possible d'être
une puissance militaire de mener une
réelle politique de défense et d'être en
amont des négociation en faveur du
désarmement c'est pour cette raison que
le groupe UMP est favorable à ce texte
et le votera je vous remercie merci mes
chers collègu dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à Jacques müer
rattaché au groupe socialiste pour 6
minutes
pas ten fais
pas monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre dommage que qu'il soit parti
madame le rapporteur chers collègues
la France fait partie des pays qui ont
signé et ratifié la Convention d'Oslo
relative aux armes à sousmunition c'est
tout à son honneur et je relève que de
nombreux pays et non des moindres s'y
sont jusqu'à présent
refusé je ne reviendrai pas ici sur les
dégâts humains collatéraux
entraînés par l'emploi de ses armes
pendant mais aussi après les conflits
armés madame le rapporteur
le rapport d'information que vous aviez
rédigé en décembre 2006 avec notre
collègue jean-Pierre Plancade était
parfaitement explicite à cet égard
monsieur le ministre main l'a également
souligné tout à l'heure je tiens à
saluer le rôle essentiel joué par les
associations et organisations non
gouvernementales notamment amnestie
internationale et Handicap International
qui ont su attirer l'attention des
gouvernements sur les conséquences
dramatiques de l'usage de ces armes à
sousmunition
en particulier pour les populations
civiles et qui ont aussi su mettre la
pression nécessaire à tous les niveaux
pour faire avancer ce
problème le projet de loi que nous
examinons ce matin vise à transcrire la
convention d'Oslo en droit français et
indéiablement il va dans la bonne
direction mais à l'instar des ONG
mobilisés sur le sujet je m'interroge
encore ce projet de loi ne me semble pas
être suffisant précis en terme de
transcription et de clarté
d'interprétation sur plusieurs points en
effet il me semble qu'une transcription
insuffisante nous est encore proposée
aujourd'hui comme si l'on ne souhaitait
pas
effaroucher certains industriels de
l'armement ou certains états
utilisateurs ou fabricants d'armes à
sousmunition et non signataires de la
convention d'Oslo avec lesquels nous
intervenons sur des théâtres d'opération
militair dans le monde ou avec lesquels
nous avons des relations économiques ou
diplomatiques
privilégié à cet égard il est
regrettable que le projet de loi ne
reprenne pas explicitement certaines
obligations positives contenues dans la
convention notamment celles qui ont
trait à nos relations avec les États non
partis à la convention avec lesquels
nous sommes en situation
d'interopérabilité sur certaines
opérations extérieur il s'agit d'une
lacune importante car rien n'est dit sur
la France sur l'attitude de la France
face à l'utilisation d'armes à
sousmunition par nos alliés non
signataires de la convention de même
n'est pas mentionné dans le projet de
loi l'interdiction claire du financement
direct ou indirect des entreprises dont
l'activité concerne toute ou partie les
armes à souousmunition n'oublions pas
que l'argent est le nerf de la guerre
une interdiction ass sortie de
sanctions mais qui oublierait les
financements de ces activités illicites
laisse la porte ouverte au contournement
des excellentes dispositions que nous
nous apprenons nous apprêtons à voter
sur ce point il convient de rappeler
qu'un certain nombre d'États signataires
ont d'ors et déjà adopté une
interdiction de ces financements ou
s'apprête à le faire il il en est de
même pour plusieurs établissements
financiers français qui ont pris les
devants et exclu toute forme de
financement et d'investissement pour
contre propre ou pour compte de tiers
dans des entreprises impliquées dans la
fabrication et le commerce d'armes à
sousmunition ainsi que de mines
antipersonnel d'autres dispositions du
texte qui nous est proposé méritent
également d'être précisé notamment
l'extension des sanctions aux personnes
morales précisé comme l'extension de
sanction ainsi que la notion de transit
des armes à sousmunition à travers notre
territoire national faute de ces
clarifications la question reste encore
posée c'est celle de la volonté réelle
de notre pays d'agir efficacement pour
l'éradication complète des armes à
sousmunition ainsi dans les relations
diplomatiqu et militaire que nous
entretenons avec plusieurs pays non
signataires comme dans les opérations
militaires menées conjointement quel
seront les moyens mis en œuvre
concrètement par la France pour que soit
étendue la signature et l'pp de la
convention d'Oslo à cet égard il me
semble qu'un signe fort pourrait être
apporté par notre pays en diminuant
symboliquement le stock d'armes à
sousmunition conservé au fin
d'entraînement ou de contremesure de
même l'acquisition de souousmunition
hors conteneur est-elle vraiment
nécessaire lorsque l'on connaît le
caractère dangereux de leur déplacement
éventuel sur le terrain et la nécessité
de procéder à leur destruction insitu
alors en conclusion j'exprime le
que nos discussions permettent
d'apporter les précisions qui manquent
pour l'instant dans ce texte qui va dans
la bonne direction mais qui reste encore
qui laisse encore plusieurs questions
importantes en suspens monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madame le
rapporteur chers collègues faisons en
sorte que notre pays soit effectivement
aux avant-postes du processus nécessaire
engagé en faveur de la suppression
totale de la fabrication et de l'usage
esunition dans le monde tel le sens des
amendements que nous déposerons
aujourd'hui je vous remercie merci mon
cher
collègue monsieur le ministre souz après
très bien donc la discussion générale
est close et nous passons à la
discussion des articles l'article
1er monsieur mer je dès que votre
campagne est finie je vous donne la
parole sur l'article
1er
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues dans l'étude d'impact du
projet de loi en matière d'impact
économique il est fait mention de quatre
industriel produisant des matériaux ou
composants pouvant entrer dans la
composition d'armes à souousmonition et
qui verront leurs exportation contrôlé
plus sévèrement et le cas échéant
interdite je cite alors cette question
me conduit monsieur le ministre à vous à
formuler ces deux questions je vous
demande pour l'information de la
représentation nationale d'être plus
explicite d'abord quant à l'identité de
ces
industriels quant à la nature des
produits fabriqués mais aussi quant à
l'application des mesures envisagées
dans l'étude d'impact prise à leur
encontre la deuxième question porte
sur la suivante dans l'hypothèse d'
interterdiction des exportations tes que
formulé dans l'étude d'impact quelles
dispositions sont envisagées par le
gouvernement pour faciliter la
reconversion des activités à vocation
militaire des entreprises concernées
vers des activités civiles monsieur le
ministre c'est une telle reconversion
pose des questions en terme de transfert
technologique du militaire vers le civil
et de financement les enjeux se situent
aussi en terme d'emploi ce qui en
période de crise ne peut évidemment être
éludé je vous remercie par avance
monsieur le ministre pour les précisions
que vous apporterez à la haute assemblée
sur ces deux questions dont l'importance
ne vous aura pas
échappé merci Monsieur müer alors un
amendement numéro 4 qui est présenté par
Jacques
müer Monsieur
M monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur chers collègues le présent
amendement a pour but d'éviter toute
ambiguité
d'interprétation du terme TranSphère en
effet aujourd'hui par exemple une
société privée étrangère qui
transiterait par les eaux françaises
pour acheminer une cargaison d'armes à
sousmunition à un état non parti ne
serait pas explicitement concerné par le
projet de loi certes dans la convention
d'Oslo la définition du terme transfert
à l'article 2 ne précise pas
explicitement que le transit des armes à
sousmunition par les États partis est
interdit en vertu de la PROE de cette
convention mais rien ne nous interdit
d'être plus précis pour éviter que les
dispositions que nous allons prendre
soient contournées d'où la nécessité de
rajouter opération de transit afin que
soit inclus dans les interdictions et
les sanctions prévu dans le projet de
loi le fait de faire passer des armes
interdites d'un bout à l'autre de notre
ou par-dessus notre territoire
national tout mode de transport
terrestre aérien ferroviaire maritime ou
fluvial tel est le sens de cet
amendement de précision merci mon cher
collègue madame la rapporteur l'avis de
la commission oui merci monsieur le
président la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement parce
qu'il nous paraît en cont en
contradiction avec le texte de la
convention d' slot puisque selon
l'amendement l'interdiction du du
transfert devrait couvrir le transit
alors que pour la convention d'Oslo le
transfert n'inclut pas le simple transit
puisqu'il faut à la fois une
introduction matérielle des armes
interdites et un transfert du droit de
propriété et du contrôle sur ses armes
donc avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
euh monsieur le sénateur simplement pour
répondre à votre question son quatre
entreprises qui sont des entreprises que
vous connaissez bien du type SNPE
rinco par ailleurs pour pour la deuxième
question il s'agit d'une part marginale
de leur activité et comme vous le savez
ce sont des entreprises sur lesquelles
il y a des des réorganisation et des
restructurations importantes qui sont en
en perspective et en projet et donc ça
n'est pas déterminant dans la activité
au point de considérer qu'il faille
mettre en place des dispositifs
particuliers de reconversion s'il le
fallait bien entendu la Délégation
Générale pour l'Armement examinerait
avec elle ce qu'il faut faire euh quant
à la quant à l'amendement lui-même
l'amendement numéro 4 ma position est
exactement la même que Madame la
rapporteur sachant que nous aurions des
difficultés d'application la question de
transit aérien quand il s'agit du survol
du territoire national ça me paraît
compliqué euh parce que vous êtes pas
dans l'avion quoi euh la la la deuxième
chose c'est que je vous rappelle qu'un
certain nombre de pays de l'Union
européenne n'ont pas signé cette
convention et donc il nous semble qu'il
faille rester dans le cadre de ce texte
et dans le cadre de la convention en
appliquant totalement intégralement la
convention mais sans aller au-delà au
risque de ne pas rendre applicable les
dispositions merci Monsieur le Ministre
explication de vote madame beniga oui
notre groupe tient à cet amendement
parce que si on prend le ce raisonnement
que la difficulté
d'application fait que finalement il
faut pas prendre la mesure à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur les
trafics de stupéfiant euh il faut bien
être capable d'araisonner un bateau et
de voir ce qu'il y a
dedans voilà dans un avion en effet
c'est difficile encore que bon on
puisse tout ce qu'on fait pour limiter
les les les transits de ces armes à
sousmunition est un moyen de rendre leur
commerce et leur utilisation de plus en
plus difficile donc nous nous estimons
que évidemment une telle mesure est
difficile à appliquer mais qu'elle est
possible à appliquer dans un certain
nombre de cas et que nous savons bien
qu'en matière de guerre et de munition
tous les moyens sont trouvés pour
contourner les embargos les
interdictions et les autres et les
autres restrictions donc il tout cela
nous incite à la prudence
et à la méfiance il faut donc être
parfaitement clair dans les dans les
intentions et les principes et nous
devons pas laisser la moindre source de
confusion bien sûr nous comprenons votre
votre remarque monsieur le ministre mais
nous estimons que ce n'est pas une
raison pour baisser la garde explication
la parole à Jean-Louis carer
oui monsieur le Président merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame le
rapporteur moi je voudrais simplement
vous dire je suis sensible à vos
arguments mais vos arguments sont des
arguments juridiques ce ne sont pas des
arguments de portée politique
excusez-moi quand on est dans ce texte
et dans son esprit que nous partageons
et que nous soutenons nous ne ferons pas
de surenchère et nous ne chercherons pas
nous différencier pour
provoquer un quelconque euh état
d'esprit de compétition c'est c'est pas
l'objet je vous assure mais il me semble
que l'argument qui est de dire parce que
nous ne pourrions pas vérifier dans les
avion s'il y a des armes à
souousmunition en transit alors ne
l'inscrivons pas est un argument qui
tombe excusez-moi on doit plutôt se
projeter en avant et dans la volonté
politique et l'écrire tant pis même si
nous savons qu'il sera très difficile de
le vérifier c'est un état d'esprit et
nous sommes d'accord sur cet état esprit
il serait regrettable que l'on s'en
prive pour des raisons purement
juridiques alors que la France mérite
vraiment de rester à l'avant-garde sur
ce
projet merci pour explication de vot
Jacques
müer monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur j'ai écouté avec beaucoup de
d'attention les observations que vous
avez faites je voudrais dire deux choses
la première c'est que dans l'amendement
précité la liste des moyens de transit
n'est pas
précisé le mot avion ne figure pas le
transit je non je l'ai mis dans mon
explication de vote c'est dans la
présentation de l'amendement que j'ai
précisé que j'ai fait la liste mais mais
c'est pas dans l'amendement dans
l'amendement on parle simplement de
transit et donc le transit sur le
territoire et sur la mer on peut le
contrôler donc je maintiens évidemment
cet amendement la deuxième raison elle
est plus politique vous l'avez dit à
juste titre la France ambitionne chers
collègues d'être aux avant-postes et
bien ne faisons pas une une traduction
une transcription minimaliste du texte
de la convention nous nous devons d'être
précis et je maintiens évidemment cet
amendement pas dans un esprit de
surenchère mais pour que nous
verrouillons toute possibilités de
contournement bien je vais mettre au
voix l'amendement numéro 4 qui est
pour qui est
contre
l'amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 5 monsieur Müller
ou monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur le le projet de loi ne
définit pas la notion de courtage qui
qui n'existe pas en droit français cert
un projet de loi concernant en principe
principe les activités de courtage a
bien été déposé en 2006 sur le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale mais il n'a
toujours pas été adopté c'est pourquoi
dans le projet en discussion la notion
de courtage non définie en Doig français
doit être remplacé par celle
d'intermédiation qui est plus large et
qui permet de rendre compte de la
réalité de l'ensemble de la chaîne
existant entre du producteur à
l'utilisateur final en effet
interviennent dans celle-ci les
courtiers les transporteurs et les
financiers il me paraît donc nécessaire
d'inclure tous ces ces acteurs du champ
d'application de la loi pour permettre à
cette dernière d'atteindre les
excellents objectifs que nous nous
sommes
fixés très bien madame le
rapporteur euh oui monsieur le sénateur
sur le fond la commission partage
totalement votre point de vue enfin
l'objectif de cet amendement puisque la
notion d'intermédiation couvre un champ
plus complet que celle du courtage au
sens strict je voudrais quand même Pr
prciser que la notion de courtage est
définie en droit français au code civil
et au code du commerce c'est plutôt la
notion d'intermédiation qui elle n'est
pas vraiment définie puisqu'il y a
effectivement un projet de loi qui vise
à définir cette intermédiation mais qui
n'a pas encore été inscrit à l'ordre du
jour du Parlement donc je reconnais
qu'il serait plus pertinent de se
référer à cette intermédiation puisque
c'est une notion plus large que le
courtage mais il faudrait que cette
notion puisse être très rapidement
définie consacrée au plan législatif
donc j'aimerais bien monsieur le
ministre au nom de la commission vous
demander votre avis votre opinion est-ce
que vous envisagez l'inscription de ce
projet de loi notre ordre du jour et
pourrait-on retenir aujourd'hui la
notion d'intermédiation avant qu'elle
était validée par la loi et tenu de
incertitudes la Commission avait décidé
de s'en remettre à la sagesse de notre
assemblée sur cette amendement encore
une
fois simplement madame la rapporteur
c'est que aujourd'hui en droit français
c'est le courtage qui existe comme vous
l'avez dit c'est ce mot-là qui est
défini à la fois dans le code du
commerce et dans le Code civil en effet
depuis juin 2007 un projet de loi a été
déposé je crois sur le bureau de votre
assemblée pour définir la notion
d'intermédiation mais dans l'état actuel
du droit positif il me semble nécessaire
de maintenir le mot de courtage si le
code vient quoi le droit positif vient à
à intégrer le mot d'intermédiation il
sera toujours temps à ce moment-là
éventuellement de déposer un amendement
pour que vous puissiez
développer les choses mais si on met
intermédiation aujourd'hui alors que ça
n'existe pas un droit positif vous
faites l'inverse c'estàdire que vous
videz vous videz le texte de son sens
donc moi je vous demande de de de
maintenir le texte en l'état et puis
éventuellement à charge lors de l'examen
du projet de loi sur
l'intermédiation de prévoir un
amendement qui permettra de compléter le
dispositif
actuel bien explication de vote Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur oui non je
souhaiterais peut-être à ce moment-là
demander demander à notre collègue
monsieur Müller de retirer cet
amendement compte tenu des explications
qui ont été données par Monsieur le
Ministre sinon je seraai contrainte
d'appeler à voter contre cet
amendement monsieur carer pour
explication de
vote moi je crois que compte tenu de la
bonne volonté de la Commission et de
madame le rapporteur et de ce que vient
de nous dire monsieur le ministre et de
l'engagement qui est pris
d'amender le texte en fonction de la
définition de
l'intermédiation il serait sage
effectivement de voter le texte en
l'état et de prendre l'engagement de
l'amender lors de la définition de
l'intermédiation merci Monsieur j'en
dédu qu'il est retiré très bien alors
deux
amendements deux amendements en
discussion commune un amendement numéro
1 qui est présenté par Monique sier
beniga donc nous souhaitons après
l'alinéa 12 insérer un alinéa ainsi
rédigé est interdit le financement
direct ou indirect de toute entreprise
de droit français ou de droit étranger
dont l'activité comprend les actions
interdites
suspenstionnées donc en fait le texte
interdit déjà la mise au point le la
convention interdit déjà la mise mis au
point la fabrication la production
l'acquisition le stockage la
conservation et cetera et l'emploi des
armes à souousmunition c'est très bien
le texte ajoute qu'il est également
interdit d'assister d'encourager ou
d'inciter quiconque à s'engager dans une
des activités interdites suspensionné
c'est encore mieux alors je vous demande
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
de faire encore un effort et de rendre
le texte bien plus précis percutant en
interdisant le financement direct ou
indirect de toute entreprise de droit
français ou de droit étranger dont
l'activité comprend les actions
interdites déjà
explicitées en effet nous considérons
qu'investir dans une entreprise
fabriquant ou faisant le commerce
d'armes à sousmunition constitue une
activité déjà interdite par la
Convention d'Oslo puisque celle-ci
condamne qu'on encourage assiste ou
insiste quiconque à s'engager dans ses
activités en la mati il est indéniable
que la meilleure façon d'encourager ou
d'inciter est encore d'investir de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent dans ce type
d'industrie ou de commerce àus mortifère
certains pays européens comme la
Belgique le Luxembourg ont d'ors et déjà
interdit ce financement dans leur loi
nationale je crois savoir que d'autres
pays qui nous sont proches la Suisse
l'Allemagne et les Pays-Bas devrai à
moyen terme adopter des législations
interdisant les financements les
investissements directs ou indirects
dans ces industries perverses c'est
pourquoi je vous demande d'adopter cet
amendement qui viendrait ainsi compléter
utilement le dispositif de la loi
proposée par le gouvernement et adopté
et amendé positivement par la commission
merci mon cher collègue amendement
numéro 2 il est présenté par notre
collègue Robert
u oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est tout
à fait dans l'esprit de ce que vient de
dire euh ma collègue socialiste
euh nous souhaitons vraiment inscrire
clairement je dis bien clairement sans
aucune ambiguïé euh dans la loi d'
l'interdiction de tout financement
direct et indirect d'entreprise engagé
euh dans ce type d'activité nous
souhaitons ainsi lever une ambiguïé
concernant la la possibilité de de
financer des entreprises fabriquant ou
faisant commerce d'armes à sousmunition
la notion d'assistance d'encouragement
ou d'incitation reprise dans l'article 1
C de la convention de SLO ne sont pas je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je le répète
suffisamment explicit et puis nous
voyons très bien la façon dont sont
contourner systématiquement ces textes
ne nous trompons pas il y a nous avons
une une un esprit aujourd'hui très
convergent sur cette loi mais il y a des
des des des groupes qui sont
complètement dont l'activité essentielle
est le contournement parce que il y a du
fric derrière il y a de l'argent il y a
des il y a des moyens financiers
considérables donc il faut être clair il
faut qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïé et
c'est l'esprit dans lequel nous voulons
nous présentons cette cet amendement euh
comme je l'ai déjà exprimé ce serait une
mesure qui traduirait concrètement la
ferme volonté de notre pays d'éliminer
ses armes et qui se mettrait en
conformité avec des réalités existant
déjà dans notre pays PS à l'étranger et
je dis aussi à mon tour je l'ai évoqué
dans mon
intervention tout à l'heure il y a des
pays comme le Luxembourg la Belgique ou
la Nouvelle-Zélande qui s'engage et
d'autres en passent de de d'être engagé
dans cette affaire la Suisse l'Allemagne
et les Pays-Bas ces pays ont compris
l'enjeu de la question de
l'investissement et du financement en
interdisant ce type d'activité et en
l'inscrivant dans la loi je vous le dis
ne soyons pas en retrait nous allons
franchir un pas important aujourd'hui ne
soyons pas en retrait il faut accepter
cette proposition qui serait un geste
politique fort je crois c'est important
ce geste et les ONG l'attendent nous
l'attendons c'est le sens de cet
amendement que nous souhaitons voir
adopté collègue madame le rapporteur
l'avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements
oui merci monsieur le Président bien
évidemment l'intention dans ces deux
amendements est parfaitement louable et
nous la partageons tous cette intention
mais ces deux amendements qui ont un
objet identique ont reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission pourquoi
parce qu'en fait ces amendements
présentent au moins deux difficultés
d'une part ils interdiraiai aux
entreprises françaises de nouer tout
partenariat avec des groupes étrangers
qui seraient concernés même de manière
très marginale ou indirect par la
fabrication d'armes à sousmunition ou de
certains de leurs composants vous le
savez de nom nom pays n'ont pas signé
cette convention de slow et pourtant
nous travaillons avec ces pays on nous
parle bien sûr de la Belgique du
Luxembourg je ne voudrais pas faire
offense à ces pays nous n'avons pas les
mêmes enjeux et je crois que notre
devoir en tant que parlementaire est
aussi de prendre nos responsabilités
alors bien évidemment nous aimerions
aller plus loin mais je crois qu'il faut
assumer nos responsabilités et enfin
aussi j'aimerais ajouter que la notion
de financement indirect pose une
évidente difficulté de contrôle par
exemple pour les fonds d'investissement
ce qui rendrait la disposition
difficilement acceptable donc je suis au
regret de maintenir notre position
d'avis défavorable monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs sénateur j'aimerais pas me
retrouver en en situation de d'accusé
j'ai vraiment incité le ministère de la
Défense à être acteur de cette
convention j'ai j'ai vraiment poussé
notre notre notre administration
appelons ça comme ça à ce que nous
soyons des partenaires du kedorsé du
ministère des Affaires étrangères pour
que la France soit exemplaire et porte
les idéaux qui sont les sien à travers
cette convention et donc qu'aujourd'hui
je me vois amené à à proposer le rejet
de ces amendements j'aimerais bien que
on on on ne on ne me passe pas pour
celui l'affreux qui voudrait limiter le
le contenu de ce dispositif écoutez il
faut dire les choses franchement je va
les dire c'est pas insulter la Belgique
et le Luxembourg que de considérer
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément des
partenariats industriels considérable
avec les industries étrangères sur les
sujets dont nous parlons c'est la France
alors on peut le regretter mais c'est
ainsi moi je pense que c'est un atout
considérable parce que si nous n'avions
pas eu notre industrie d'armement nous
n'aurions pas pu développer destat
d'industrie civile dont aujourd'hui nous
considérons que la France peut s'en
orgueillir comme l'industrie
aéronautique ou l'industrie
spatiale nous avons 250000 à 300000
salariés qui travaillent dans
l'industrie d'armement française cette
industrie d'armement vous êtes en
permanence en train d'appeler à ce
qu'elle nous des partenariats européens
et que nous construisions l'industrie
européenne de défense nos partenaires
européens ne ne ont signé une convention
qui ne prévoit voit pas je le rappelle
qui ne prévoit pas ce dispositif et donc
je je vous demande de ne pas être plus
royaliste que le roi ou de ou de vouloir
stipuler pour autrui moi aussi je je le
souhaite au plus profond de moi-même
mais quand vous avez en tête qu'il n'y a
que aujourd'hui 40 pays qui ont ratifié
cette convention que sur l'ensemble des
pays d' l'Union européenne à part le
Belgique et le Luxembourg aucun ne
prévoit un dispositif de ce genre vous
voyez bien que vous rendez la tâche de
l'industrie française extrêmement
compliqué même avec des entreprises dont
l'activité totalement marginale et dont
on voit bien que les conditions
d'application et les difficultés
d'application serait considérable
comment allez savoir que tel ou tel
grand groupe européens ou
américains il y a même des pays de
l'Union comme la Pologne avec lesquels
nous essayons de nouer un certain nombre
de partenariats industriels quion
purement et simplement n'ont pas signé
la Convention et donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on se refuse toute
convention avec tout tout accord
Industri avec ces pays alors que vous
appelez en permanence de vos vœux de de
nouer des relations industrielles avec
tout tous les anciins pays d'Europe
centrale et orientale pour pour
développer une industrie européenne qui
soit capable de pouvoir rivaliser et
d'être en en concurrence avec
l'industrie américaine donc je je je
vous demande simplement de bien vouloir
considérer que ça n'est pas votre
intention est formidable tout le monde
la partage la seule chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est totalement
inapplicable à moins
de vouloir handicaper lourdement une
industrie dont vous appelez dans de
nombreuses interventions et dans de
nombreux courriers à faire en sorte
qu'elle puisse être maintenu au niveau
pour permettre aux 300000 salariés
français de continuer à pouvoir
travailler merci Monsieur le Ministre
pourlication la parole est à JeanLouis
car puis à
Monique du vote
moi je suis un petit peu étonné
quoi j'interviens en disant qu'on est
dans Mme état d'esprit non on n'est pas
dans le même état d'esprit pardon de le
dire avec une certaine gravité vous me
rappelez la dérive du Grenel 1 quoi bah
oui oui vous êtes pour la lutte contre
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous êtes pour tout ça et puis quand il
y a un problème dans l'agriculture vous
l'êtes plus puis quand il y a un
problème ici ou là vous
renoncez et là c'est pareil alors bon
vos arguments monsieur le ministre il y
en a qui sont respectables qui sont
compréhensibles qui sont admissibles
mais il faut savoir si ici on est pour
éradiquer la fabrication et l'emploi des
armes à sousmunition ou si on a tout un
tas de bonnes raisons économiques
industriel ou autre qui ferait que on
abandonnerait l'objet initial de ce
texte alors c'est bien gentil c'est bien
sympathique de nous dire mais non votre
esprit est louable c'est intéressant
c'est tout ce que vous voulez mais on
peut pas le faire pas encore ça viendra
non moi je pense que la France doit
jouer un rôle et un rôle de leadership
et ce rôle de leadership sans rien
casser monsieur le ministre on n'est pas
des vatt en guerre on n pas en train VI
de vous dire renoncer à tout contrat
mais essayer par la conviction de faire
connaître nos positions et d'obtenir
justement de nos partenaires plutôt
qu'il s'alignne sur nos positions que le
contraire que nous nous aligner sur des
positions contraires à ce que nous
aurions voté donc moi je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très important que
c'est quelque chose de de très net et
que nous devons vis-à-vis de toutes
celles et de tous ceux qui nous
manifestent qui manifestent cet
attachement autour de ce texte qui nous
ont initié qui nous ont convainc
qui nous ont nourri qui nous ont aidé
qu'on doit leur montrer que vraiment
notre attachement à l'éradication de ces
armes est indéfectible et qu'elle ne
peut pas faire l'objet d'un marchandage
futtil
important pour l'avenir de certaines
unités de fabrication de notre pays pour
explication not la parole est à Monique
cier ben Guiga oui je ne répéterai pas
ce que vient de dire mon collègue mais
il y a il y a quand même un problème la
France a une industrie d'armement et et
cette industrie d'armement heureusement
elle elle emploie 300000 personnes mais
si nous devons continuer à avoir des
accords interentreprises des joint
venture et cetera avec des entreprises
en particulier israélienne parce que le
nom que vous n'avez pas cité c'est
Israël
hein avec des c'est surtout avec et tout
à fait normalement avec Israël que nous
avons beaucoup de collaborations sur le
plan de l'armement et évidemment nous
savons bien que les industries
israéliennes fabriquent des bombes à
sous munition parce queisraël en est un
gros utilisateur donc vous ne voulez pas
aller plus loin parce que ça porte une
atteinte à ces ces coopérations là
ministre non mais je d'une part c'est
pas la question de nos relations
industrielles avec Israël très
franchement on a une coopération
totalement accessoire avec Israël c'est
pas absolument pas le sujet le sujet il
est très simple je vais prendre des
exemple vous dites financement direct et
indirect alors qu'est-ce que fait
qu'est-ce que devient une entreprise
comme
EADS je vous demand pose la question
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait lorsqu'elle
décide de de passer des accords avec
l'industrie américaine et avec ses
filiales américaines vous je prends un
autre exemple des CNS des CNS est en
train de travailler sur un des acccords
avec la Pologne on
arrête le programme à 400m vous êtes
tous demandé vous m'avez pendant 9 mois
interrogé en disant alors monsieur le
ministre le programme à 400 m est-ce que
la France et l'Europe vont être capable
de faire un avion de transport militaire
Vous faites quoi vous arrêtez l'avion de
transport militaire alors 4è sujet nous
avons décidé de faire un programme
s'appelle Musis d'observation
satellitaire pour que l'Europe soit en
mesure de ne pas dépendre de
l'observation américaine et que nous
ayons une capacité stratégique
d'autonomie d'observation qui soit
propre à l'Europe qui nous permette de
pouvoir décider par nous-même si telle
ou telle crise pour pouvoir observer ces
crises et avoir cette capacité cette
autonomie de décision vis stratégique on
arrête ce programme et bien si parce que
quand vous dites l'interdiction de
financement direct et indirect ça veut
dire qu'à chaque fois que vous lancez un
programme avec une industrie européenne
d'un pays non signataire ou n'ayant pas
ratifié cette convention ou ne le
prévoyant pas dans son droit positif ça
veut dire clairement et simplement que
vous arrêtez à peu près tous les
partenariats industriels possibles et
imaginaablees mais par ailleurs cessz de
considérer que la question est avec
Israël nous avons une coopération
Industri avec Israël qui est extrêmement
non mais je dis ça madame le sénateur
c'est pas le sujet c'est absolument pas
le sujet le seul partenariat que nous
avons avec Israël c'est sur c'est sur
les drones et encore de façon
extrêmement limitée donc c'est vraiment
pas le sujet la question est que si vous
décidez d'adopter un tel dispositif
alors que les autres pays Européens ne
l'ont pas adopter et bien clairement
tous les programmes que vous faites
tomberont sous le coup de ce texte et
donc il s'agit pas simplement des
espèces de Vat en guerre ou de soutenir
une industrie de défense porteur de la
de la misère et de la mort de de
l'humanité c'est que très clairement il
faut rester j'allais dire dans le
domaine du du possible c'est tout
voilà explication la parole est à Robert
u oui monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je crois
que nous touchons à au fond euh nous
avons dit j'ai moi-même dit dans mon
intervention dès le départ combien nous
approuvions globalement ce texte mais là
à travers la discussion nous voyons
apparaître des questions en tous les cas
en ce qui me concerne fondamental et qui
pose le problème de notre industrie
d'armement et de sa place dans
l'économie française ou dans l'économie
internationale et donc le problème du
commerce des armes il faut appeler un
chat un chat et et et là si nous nous
battons sur cet amendement c'est que
nous ne voulons pas qu'il y ait
contournement en fait du dispositif et
de la loi mais Mons le ministre a dit
tout à l'heure que il fallait pas que
nous handicapions notre industrie
d'armement certes encore qu'on peut
regarder comment faire autrement avec
l'industrie d'armement je considère
aujourd'hui que la fuite en avant qui
consiste pour des raisons économiques à
donner une place au commerce des armes
dans le monde et en France aussi et donc
pouvant être contourné dans le
dispositif qu'on évoque là est quelque
chose de gravissime nous voyons bien
avec le débat qui se passe en ce moment
sur la Grèce comment un certain nombre
de banques pour mieux récupérer
et mettre en œuvre leur contrat d'armes
avec la Grèce sont en avance sur ceux
qui veulent effectivement mettre en
œuvre l'ustérité donc VO je crois qu'il
y a quelque chose de fond là c'est pas
le débat essentiel peut-être décidé
aujourd'hui mais il faudra bien que nous
ayons le débat sur ce problème du
commerce des armes et la part de
l'industrie d'armement dans notre
industrie si c'est la le seul vecteur
économique de notre puissance ça pose un
problème majeur pour explication
monsieur le ministre je vous en prie
je je vais arrêter mais mais simplement
c'est pas le commerce des armes ce dont
je vous parle c'est le programme
européen c'est programme que nous
faisons en commun on est très loin du
commerce des armes il s'agit de
programme européens que nous appelons
tous de nos vux pour mutualiser et et
réduire le niveau de dépense donc on est
très loin de ça et puis monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur quand des sénateurs
communistes prendront la parole pour
évoquer la situation de tel ou t
entrepris français
et notamment d'entreprises comme DCNS
comme la SNPE et cetera je j'aurai
l'occasion d'évoquer avec vous de
d'évoquer avec eux les propos que vous
venez de tenir parce que très
franchement des entreprises les
entreprises françaises heureusement qu'
qu'elles sont en mesure dans les limites
de la réglementation de pouvoir
s'engager dans des programmes avec un
certain nombre de pays étrangers pour
explication de vote la parole est
monsieur je vous rappelle que dans le
règlement on nintervient qu'une fois en
explication de vote et je suis ma
fonction est de le faire respecter
Monsieur M vous avez la parole parmi les
les amendements que nous avons déposé
c'est pour nous évidemment l'amendement
central l'amendement centrale parce que
nous estimons que il est d'abord
nécessaire d'inscrire cette disposition
dans la loi le texte est clair sur la
production et le stockage je regrette
pour ma part que nous n'ayons pas
clarifi sur le transit mais le texte ne
peut pas rester silencieux sur les
activités financières nous savons que
cette activité de
production de production militaire et
notamment d'armes à souousmunition sont
particulièrement lucratives et donc le
financement est au cœur du problème par
ailleurs il s'agit de marchés qui sont
en développement il faut le dire sur les
théâtres d'opération dans le monde nous
ne pouvons pas aujourd'hui vous avez
évoqué des arguments européens
internationaux mais ça c'est aussi une
réalité ce sont des marchés qui se
développent alors où nous prenons notre
part pour éviter que l'on continue de
produire et d'utiliser ces armes dans le
monde ou bien nous passons à côté du
problème donc sur le fond nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas intégrer cette
disposition deuxè aspect c'est possible
c'est possible certains pays ont été
évoqués je rajouterai la
Nouvelle-Zélande la Belgique l'Irlande
le Luxembourg la Norvège le Rwanda et le
Liban le Liban aussi a pris cette
disposition ça vous fait sourire mais
c'est une réalité un bon nombre de pays
aujourd'hui prennent leur part au combat
mondial contre ces armes à
souousmunition et bien prenonsla aussi
notre part certains pays ont déjà pris
cette disposition d'autres s'apprêtent à
le faire la
Suisse la Hollande l'Allemagne aussi
leur parlement ont pris des motions ça
va se traduire dans le droit national il
y a aussi des groupes économiques qui
ont pris ces disposition des banques
françaises AXA BNP pariba le Crédit
Agricole la Société générale je vais pas
les citer tous Natixis ce sont autant de
groupes financiers qui à la demande des
ONG ont pris leur responsabilité et ont
cessé de financer ces activités alors si
des groupes financiers ont pu le faire
nous aussi on doit être capable en tant
que parlementaire d'inscrire dans la loi
l'interdiction de ce financement je suis
convaincu que c'est un des moyens
essentiel pour que d'autres pays aussi
nous suivent je vous remercie je veux
mettre au voix l'amendement numéro
1 qui est
pour qui est contre l'amendement n'est
pas adopté sur l'amendement numéro 2 y y
a-t-il des explications de vote je n'en
vois pas si Monsieur carer
la seule chose que je voulais ajoutter
dans ce débat où on a pas tout dit mais
où on a dit l'essentiel c'est que bien
sûr que je ne me permettrai pas de
balayer d'un revers deain les arguments
de de de monsieur le ministre de la
défense mais je voudrais dire à monsieur
le ministre de la Défense que pour moi
il est assez facile d'y répondre qu'il
suffit que les partenaires de ADS ou de
DCNS euh puisse sortir des activités
interdites de partenariat industriel et
et et la faire réjouer pourquoi faut--il
que ce soit nous qui nous euh mettions
en bas de l'échelle pour poursuivre et
pourquoi ne peut-on pas leur demander un
effort à eux si on est sûr de ce que
l'on veut faire en faire je ne comprends
pas cette espèce de de de méthode qui
consiste à préparer ou à présenter des
textes qui ont l'assentiment de tout ce
qui de demande qui comme le miroir aux
alouettes nous permettent d'envisager
que ce sera très très bien puis tout
d'un coup par derrière un coup de
freinage extraordinaire pour permettre
tous les partenariats non moi je
maintiens monsieur le ministre qu'on
doit pouvoir trouver avec un groupe
comme ADS compte tenu des pays qui sont
partenaires et comp tenu de l'état
d'esprit de ceux qui le financent
euh facilement une issue par la sortie
justement de ce groupe de partenariat
qui correspondrait à des activité
interdite donc je pense que c'est une
fausse méthode très bien je vais mettre
au voie l'amendement numéro 2 qui est
pour qui est contre l'amendement numéro
2 n'est pas adopté un amendement numéro
6 il est présenté par Jacques
müer monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues le projet de loi prévoit des
mesures de transparence sur la
destruction des stocks et la rétention
d'armes à sousmunition et précise un
nombre maximum d'armes à sousmunition et
de sousmunition retenu à des fins
d'entraînement de nos troupes qui
peuvent être confrontés à à ce type
d'armes cependant je m'interroge sur les
besoins réels de notre armée en la
matière un nombre moins important ne
pourrait-il pas être afficher ne
serait-ce pas donner un signe clair de
notre volonté de réduire et d'interdire
à terme ces armes à soumunition dans le
monde d'où ma proposition de
symboliquement d'une centaine d'unités
le nombre maximum d'armes détenu au
terme du délai prévu de 8
années merci madame le
rapporteur peut-être examiner en même
temps les amendements 6 et 7 de Monsieur
Müller si oui parfaitement si vous
voulez c'est très simple le projet de
loi est très clair il propose de ramener
de 500 à 400 le nombre maximal d'armes
et l'amendement suivant donc supprime la
possibilité prévue par la convention de
détenir des sousmunitions hors
containeur je voudrais quand même
renvoyer notre collègue et ami Monsieur
le Sénateur Müller à l'étude d'impact
qui a été jointe au projet de loi et qui
précise qu'il existe environ 200 types
d'armes à sousmunition dans le monde
détenu à 90 % par des États qui n'ont
pas signé la convention d'os slot donc
très honnêtement mon cher collègue
quand vous avez 200 types d'armes à
sousmunition que nous pouvons penser que
dans les années qui viennent le nombre
de ces armes à sousmunition de ces types
d'armes risqu encore d'augmenter
franchement détenir 500 armes à
sousmunition c'est très peu nous en
avons besoin pour la formation de nos
des mineurs nous en avons besoin pour
l'information de nos forces et pour vous
parler très franchement moi ce nombre me
semble même faible à titre de
comparaison il y a 5000 mines
antiersonnel qui sont autorisé par la
France voyez le décalage 5000 armes à
sousmunition pardon 5000 mines
antipersonnel 500 armes à sousmunition
donc vraiment je crois que je
souhaiterais vous demander de retirer
votre amendement sinon la commission
émettra un avis défavorable merci Madame
ministre simplement nous avons recensé
218 types d'armes à sousmunition donc
bon ça fait
deux par type il faut quand même qu'on
entraîne nos des mineurs il faut qu'on
soit en mesure de mener une expertise
parce que nos hommes ils se retrouvent
ensuite sur des terrains sur lesquels
éventuellement ils sont confrontter à
ces armes à sousmunition donc je je je
veux pas être désagréable mais je
pourrais l'être
là
bien explication de vote sur le 6
monsieur muler m à aurez bien compris
qu'il s'agissait monsieur le ministre
d'un amendement d'appel et je souhaitais
avoir une explication publique que vous
m'avez donné et donc je retire les deux
amendements qui relèvent vous l'avez
compris de la même
philosophie donc vous voyez que le
problème s'est réglé tout seul alors si
ces se sont retirés nous en arrivons
maintenant un amendement 8 les
amendements 8 et 3 qui sont en
discussion commune alors l'amendement 8
monsieur muler
vous levez les mains désespérément mais
c'est pas moi qui dépose des amendements
donc fa que je vous donne la
parole non je ne suis pas désespéré
rassurez-vous
monsurzy monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues la convention d'Oslo énonce
son article 9 que chaque État parti
prend toutes les mesures nationales
d'application y compris l'imposition de
sanction pénale pour prévenir et
réprimer toute activité interdite à un
état parti en vertu de la convention qui
serait mené par des personne je cite ou
sur un territoire sous sa juridiction ou
son contrôle vous aurez compris que le
terme personne dans le texte de la
convention ne précise pas s'il s'agit de
personne physique ou morale même si cela
est sous-entendu la nature de la
convention interdit clairement la
production d'armes à sousmunition ce qui
est le fait d'entreprise qui Cuse par
conséquent de la qualité de personne
morale mais la manière dont est rédigé
la proposition d'article L23 44 ti 10 de
notre projet de loi laisse entendre
qu'elle ne s'appliquait qu'aux personnes
physiques je cite un français et non aux
personnes morales françaises pouvant
commettre des infractions à l'étranger
via notamment le représentant d'où notre
proposition d'amendement qui vise à
apporter cette précision qui nous
apparaît rigoureusement indispensable ne
pas le faire serait permettre une
interprétation de la loi ouvrant la
porte à des pratiques contraires
évidemment à l'esprit de la
convention amendement numéro 3 présenté
par Robert
u monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je vais dans le même esprit
notre collègue Müller nous proposons
dans cet amendement après les mots par
un Français d'insérer les mots
ou une personne
morale ceci je l'ai dit dans mon
intervention tout à l'heure afin de
compléter ce texte en élargissant la
compétence extraterritoriale de nos
juridictions à la possibilité de
poursuivre aussi des personnes morales
pour ces délits en effet conformément à
l'article 9 de la Convention d'Oslo le
projet de loi prévoit que la loi
française s'applique au délit relatif
aux armes à soumunition commis hors du
territoire de la République tel qu'il
est actuellement rédigé cet article ne
mentionne que les personnes physiques ça
vient d'être dit par le terme personne
le texte ne précise pas s'il s'agit de
personnes physique et moral
ou moral on peut considérer que ce sont
les deux ce qui est toujours le cas
d'entreprise qui disposent de la qualité
de personnes morales ce projet
laisserait donc entendre que la loi ne
s'appliquerait qu'au aux personnes
physiques et non aux personnes morales
personnes morales qui pourraiit
commettre une infraction à l'étranger
via un de ses représentants il y a là un
vide un vide que nous souhaitons combler
pour que les infractions de ce type
commises par des entreprises puissent
également être sanctionné et ainsi que
la loi couvre explicitement les
infractions qu'elles soi commises par
des personnes physiques ou par des
personnes morales en dehors du
territoire français voilà pourquoi nous
proposons de retenir cet
amendement merci mon cher collègue
madame le rapporteur votre avis oui mes
chers collèguue le projet de loi déroge
déjà au principe de territorialité de la
loi pénale et de double incrimination
pour réprimer les infraction à la loi
française commise à l'étranger par un
ressortissant français quand bien même
les activités en cause seraiit autorisé
par le pays en question les amendements
8 et 3 vise à préciser que cette
disposition s'applique aussi bien aux
personnes physiques qu'aux personnes
morales le projet de loi a retenue sur
ce point je le rappelle une disposition
absolument identique à celle qui
s'applique pour les mines
antipersonnelles et il paraît logique
qu'un même régime s'applique à ces deux
types d'armes interdites en tout état de
cause l'amendement numéro 3 ne peut pas
être retenu car il ne précise pas que
seules les personnes morales françaises
sont concernées par contre nous nous
sommes interrogés sur l'amendement
numéro 8 et nous aimerions obtenir
l'avis du gouvernement et de Monsieur le
Ministre afin qu'il nous indique si
comme cela semble être le cas la
formulation un Français couvre bien les
personnes physiques et les personnes
morale dans ce cas l'amendement numéro 8
serait bien évidemment inutile et je
vous demande de le rappeler en
conséquent je vous propose un avis
défavorable sur l'amendement numéro 3 et
la sagesse du gouvernement sur
l'amendement numéro 8 monsieur le
ministre il faut bien entendu que les
personnes physiques et morales soient
concerné par ce dispositif et pour nous
il est très clair que le texte tel qu'il
est rédigé concerne tant les personnes
physiques que les personnes
morales
merci vous nous donnez la position du
gouvernement sur les deux amendements
défavorbles très
bien la parole est à Monique cier Guiga
pour explication de vote je crains que
je crains vraiment que devant un
tribunal la formulation du texte tel
qu'il est rédigé un Français ne
s'applique qu'à une personne physique un
individu et il suffira d'avoir
l'habilité de s'installer dans un
système de de société pour échapper à
l'incrimination parce que là la société
ne sera pas responsable donc l'individu
par voie de conséquence ne le sera pas
non plus donc c'est pour ça que nous ne
retirerons pas notre amendement parce
que nous pensons que juridiquement un
Français ça ne désigne pas une
entreprise une société
euh monsieur le ministre très
franchement je vous demande de retirer
votre amendement puisque depuis 2004 le
code pénal français prévoit que sans
qu'il y ait besoin de le de le préciser
que toutes les infractions et les
incriminations en droit pénal français
s'applique pour les personnes physiques
comme pour les personnes morales c'est
de c'est le texte de la République
française depuis 2004 c'est
inutile bien pour explication de vote la
parole est à Jacques
müer au moment où nous adoptons un texte
dont chacun aura mesurer la la la portée
un texte fort euh je trouve qu'il faut
être précis monsieur le ministre vous
dites je pense que le français la notion
du terme français incorpore aussi les
personnes moral pour ma part je trouve
qu'il faut faciliter le travail des
juges et écrire les choses très
précisément très clairement nous
maintenons
l'amendement très bien pas d'autre
explication de vote alors je vais mettre
au voix l'amendement numéro 8
présenté par monsieur müer qui est
pour qui est
contre l'amendement n'est pas
adopté même vote pour l'amendement
numéro 3 présenté par Monsieur
Hu même vote je vous en remercie nous
allons donc mettre au voie l'article
1er qui est
pour l'article
1er qui contre je n'en vois pas
l'article 1er est adopté alors l'article
1 bis pas d'amendement je vous propose
sauf opposition de le considérer comme
adopté après l'article 1 B un amendement
numéro 9 monsieur müer
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues dans la mesure où le présent
projet de loi constitue une
transcription de la la convention d'Oslo
en drroit National les obligations
positives contenues dans l'article 21
paragraphe 12 2 de la Convention qui
concerne
l'interopérabilité doivent être prises
et mentionnées explicitement dans notre
projet de loi elle constitue en effet un
complément nécessaire aux dispositions
qui figurent dans l'article L
2344-3 ne pas le faire reviendrait à
n'envisager qu'une transcription
incomplète de l'article 21 de la
Convention en effet la France
n'intervient que très rarement seule sur
les théâtres d'opération merci Monsieur
Madame le monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires
étrangères monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues nous sommes là
typiquement devant une rédaction qui est
un vœu strictement pieux qui n'est en
aucune manière normative et qui est un
dévoiement de la loi parce que la loi
elle est elle a fonction
de permettre ou d'interdire et de
sanctionner tous ceux qui
enfraignent ces dispositions là il
s'agit d'une pétition de principe d'une
déclaration à laquelle on peut souscrire
et au demeurant totalement inutile
encourager les États non partis à la
convention à la ratifier certes mais
enfin il y aura des
réfractaires deuxièmement comment
ferez-vous pour les sanctionner ces
réfractaires ça n'a pas sa place dans la
loi et à la fin vous dites la France
notifie au gouvernement de tous les
États non parti à la présente convention
ses obligations au TER C mais à partir
du moment on vote la convention
elle sera notifiée à tous donc ces
dispositions sont inutiles j'insiste sur
le fait qu'il faut chasser de nos lois
toutes ces déclarations votives qui
l'alourdissent et qui ne mèent à
rien merci monieur madame le rapporteur
la position de la Commission oui nous
partageons totalement la position de
monsieur le Président de la Commission
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire le
gouvernement a déjà fait énormément et
c'est tout à son honneur pour cette
convention d'os slow je voudrais
rappeler aussi ce que j'ai dit en
commission lors de la conférence des
ambassadeurs le ministre des Affaires
étrangères nous a bien dit qu'il avait
envoyé des instructions à tous les
postes pour leur demander de convaincre
les états dans lesquels il se trouvait
en poste de tout faire pour convaincre
ces états de signer la convention d'
donc je crois que vraiment il est déjà
répondu à l'objet de cet amendement qui
effectivement n'est pas recevable d'un
point de vue juridique dans ce texte là
donc je demanderai à notre collègue de
retirer son amendement mais peut-être
que le ministre souhaiterait aussi nous
dire quelques mots de toutes ces actions
qui sont menées par le
gouvernement collègue à lui donner la
parole comme c'est extraordinaire
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
même avis que le président et la
rapporteur
très bien y a-t-il des explications de
vote madame cier benigard oui bien
écoutez nous souscrivons tout à fait au
propos de Monsieur de Roran notre
précédente Commission en effet il faut
éviter de faire des lois qui ne sont pas
destinées à être appliqué seulement ce
que nous voudrions bien c'est que le
chef du gouvernement et le président de
la République entendent le propos de
Monsieur de et que nous cessionions de
voir arriver sur le bureau de cette
assemblée des textes qui ne seront
jamais
qui ne sont pas destinés à l're mais qui
sont destinés uniquement à faire de la
communication donc nous nous ne
cherchons pas faire de la communication
en accord avec Monsieur Müller nous
retirons cet amendement mais nous
voudrions bien que nous souhaitons
vivement que cela soit appliqué à tous
les textes qui encombrent cette
assemblée très bien l'amendement est
retiré et un champ de réflexion immense
est ouvert alors sur les articles 2 3 4
et 5 je n'ai pas de d'amendement je vous
propose de les considérer sans position
comme adopté je vous en remercie je vais
mettre au voix l'ensemble du projet de
loi il y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote global madame S
miga monsieur u oui une explication de
vote très brève il est évident que nous
nous voterons ce texte de loi nous
estimons qu'il est la continuation non
pas l'achèvement mais la continuation
d'un processus auquel nous avons
beaucoup apporté et euh quels que soient
les les les insuffisance que nous y
trouvons nous estimons qu'il doit être
voté la parole est à roberu pour
explication de vote oui
monsieur ce débat intéressant qui nous a
permis de de sortir parfois du du thème
précis et y compris quand nous avons
évoqué la dimension économique de plus
en plus importante à mes yeux euh du
commerce des armes et et et avec la
volonté monsieur le ministre je
évidemment pour moi de
concevoir en aucun cas une démarche qui
viserait à toucher à nos activités
économiques à l'emploi des industries
d'armement mais je reviens sur le débat
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui ce débat
est intéressant je souhaitais je
souhaitais exprimer ma satisfaction
concernant cette avané décisives et les
modifications significatives apporté à
ce texte et notamment celle dont nousous
sommes fait l'interprète à travers nos
nos amendements tout n'est pas terminé
pour autant il nous faut rester vigilant
particulièrement auprès des grandes
puissances militaires on a vu le nombre
de ces grandes puissances qui ne sont
pas signataires aujourd'hui de de la
convention enfin je souhaite pour
terminer saluer la qualité du travail
des ONG teles qu'handicap et amnistie
internationale avec lesquels nous avons
particulièrement travaillé sur ce
dossier des bombes à sous iition et qui
a permis d'aboutir à ce texte qui de mon
point de vue est un texte d'une grande
portée nous vrons donc ce texte merci la
Jean-Louis Jacques müer puis Jean-Louis
carer et Robert
delpia monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues la convention d'Oslo constitue
un progrès indéniable pour
l'humanité 103 pays j'allais dire
seulement l'ont
signé 24 seulement l'ont ratifié et même
si la France n'est que le 20e sur 24 à
l'avoir fait elle s'engage elle s'engage
à la différence d'autres grandes
puissance euh ou qui se prétendent
grande puissance et c'est tout à son
honneur pour notre part nous nous
regrettons tout de même monsieur le
ministre que pour finalement revendiquer
la première place vous l'avez dit dans
votre discours introductif je crois
vraiment qu'il aurait fallu clarifier
notre texte sur les les deux questions
de fond la question de la personnalité
morale et la question du
financement cela étant ce projet de loi
même imparfait constitue un engagement
essentiel
et nous le vterons les collègues mes
collègu vert se prononce aussi dans ce
sens nous voterons ce texte simplement
nous ne nous abstiendrons de nous
Français de donner la leçon aux autres
nous n'aurons nous pourrons pas
revendiquer la première place d'autres
assemblées ont fait mieux que nous mais
nous voterons ce texte pour explication
la paré ta jean-hou
carer bien sûr que je ne reprendrai pas
les explications de vote avec lesquelles
je suis en acccord j'ajouterai
simplement pour Monsieur le Ministre et
pour la Haute Assemblée que je je suis
très sensible à l'engagement qui a été
pris par la volonté de de d'amender et
de substituer le terme intermédiation au
terme courtage parce que ce n'est pas
aussi aussi léger que cela ce type
d'amendement il nous permettra de
prendre en compte les différents aspects
y compris les aspects industriels et
financiers par la substitution de ces
termes donc je souhaite que ça reste en
mémoire et en rappelant cet engagement
je vot avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme ce
texte tel qu' nous est proposé merci mon
cher collègue la parole
pourert petite remarque alors c'est une
explication de vot explication
de je peux pas vous donner la parole
voors j pas sur les mots monsieur le
Président une explication de vote simple
alors je voterai avec enthousiasme aussi
et je félicite le président le
rapporteur et le ministre pour ce texte
mais je voulais faire une petite
remarque parler d'encombrement de
l'Assemblée moi je me demande si on
devrait pas se reposer la question
monsieur le Président sur
les amendements qui sont déposés
débattus en commission et qui reviennent
à l'identique dans la dans la salle en
séance et et qui sont quel parfois même
par les mêmes personnes alors je me
demande si l'encouement on devrait pas
réfléchir à modifier peut-être ce que
nous avons
adopté monsieur le ministre dans
l'opposition
moi je je voudrais je voudrais
simplement dire
que comme j'ai comme j'ai pu être fier
de de porter la Loi sur l'indemnisation
des victimes des ESS nucléaires je suis
fier en tant que ministre de la Défense
au nom du gouvernement j'allais dire au
nom de la France plus globalement de
porter ce projet de loi sur le
l'interdiction des armes à sousmunition
je crois que c'est un immense progrès je
pense que c'est une grande fierté pour
notre pays d'être la première puissance
militaire à s'engager dans ce chemin et
de s'engager tellement activement que
nous procéderons à l'élimination de
toutes ces armes avant la date ultime et
nous sommes un exemple puisque nous
porterons ce message à travers le monde
à travers notre politique étrangère mais
aussi à travers le message que nous
serons capables de porter dans les
alliances qui sont les nôtres puisque la
voix de la France compte la voix de la
France porte parce que elle repose sur
une puissance militaire importante et
donc nous pourrons largement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sans orgueillir
d'avoir avant les autres ratifier cette
convention et d'avoir ensuite intégré
dans notre droit positif de tels
dispositifs je crois que ça peut
globalement être un instrument de un
objet de fierté partagé par tous les
groupes de ces
assemblées
merci je mets donc au voix l' du projet
de loi qui est
pour je constate l'unanimité et vous en
remercie le projet de loi est donc
adopté c'est la fin de cette séance
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire cet après-midi 15h avec
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement merci de votre fidélité à
très bientôt sur notre
antenne